schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute live
unsere Woche die hat begonnen mit den
Gesprächen zwischen der Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock und dem russischen
Außenminister lavrow und unsere Woche
endet heute mit part 2 im
ukraine-konflikt denn heute kam der
amerikanische Außenminister Anthony
blinken mit lavrov zusammen denn da gibt
es immer noch Gesprächsbedarf und zwar
haben sich die beiden getroffen in Genf
auf neutralem Boden kamen sie zusammen
zu ihren diplomatischen Gesprächen und
was dabei herumkam darüber wollen wir
heute sprechen es gab zumindest einen
Handschlag das sehen wir gleich im Bild
das war also der Auftakt heute dieser
diplomatischen Gespräche die sind nötig
denn noch immer sollen bis zu 100.000
russische Soldaten an der Grenze zur
Ukraine stehen Anthony blinken sagte
gestern bei uns im heute journal wenn
auch nur ein russischer Soldat in die
Ukraine eindringen würde dann habe man
ein profundes Problem er benannte das
ein ganz klarer Angriff egal ob es sich
zum Einen oder 1000 Soldaten handelt es
gibt also Gesprächsbedarf und auch eure
Fragen und Kommentare die nehmen wir
gerne jederzeit hier auf direkt per Mail
oder im Stream ihr kennt das ja schon
und wir können jetzt zuerst sprechen am
Anfang der Sendung mit unserem
Korrespondenten vor Ort in Genf mit
Florian neuhahn schönen guten Tag
Florian hallo
hallo nochmals du hast den Tag und diese
Gespräche und beobachtet kam da denn
heute schon irgendwie kann man da weiter
in dieser verfahrenen Situation was ist
dabei herausgekommen
ich würde sagen man kann da von einer
kleinen Atempause sprechen das
wichtigste meines Erachtens ist die
Beteuerung und die Bekräftigung beider
Seiten dass man sich auf einen weiteren
Dialog einlässt das haben hier sowohl
der US-Außenminister Antony blinken als
auch sein russischer Kollege Sergei
lavroff nach dem Gespräch in ihren
jeweiligen Pressekonferenzen betont also
man redet weiter das ist die gute
Nachricht die vielleicht weniger gute
Nachricht ist dass man inhaltlich nicht
weitergekommen ist dass die Positionen
da weiterhin verhärtet sind das ist kein
Zeichen von echter Entspannung gibt
insofern ist das Fazit bislang eher
gemischt nächste Woche das wurde heute
ebenfalls klar wird die USA werden die
USA eine schriftliche Antwort an
Russland schicken und diese Antwort
werden sie auf die russischen
Forderungen nach sogenannten
Sicherheitsgarantien eingehen russland
will ja dass die NATO ihre Truppen aus
Osteuropa abzieht und dass sie
ausschließt weitere Mitglieder im Osten
Europas etwa die Ukraine aufzunehmen
diese Forderungen hält der Westen halten
die USA für unerfüllbar
und dann wird man eben sehen wenn jetzt
die USA diese Antwort abschicken wie
reagiert dann Russland entweder mit
einem weiteren Dialog eine Möglichkeit
auch eines Gespräches zwischen beiden
und Putin zwischen den beiden
Präsidenten oder man reagiert mit einer
Eskalation und das ist die große Frage
bei der wir auch heute nicht wirklich
schlauer geworden sind du hast es
angesprochen da gibt es stand jetzt noch
zwei sehr verschiedene Positionen und
vor allem auch zwei narrative Russland
damit wollen wir mal anfangen die haben
heute das narrativ bedient dass sie
gesagt haben wir sind doch ein
friedlicher Nachbar und wir haben da
auch ein O-Ton von lavrov in den wollen
wir jetzt erstmal kurz reinhören
ich möchte sagen dass Russland niemals
die ukrainischen Menschen bedroht hat
wie ich bereits sagte wir warten auf
eine schriftliche Antwort und wenn das
passiert ist dann planen wir auf unserer
Ebene die neuen Kontakte Präsident Putin
ist stets bereit für Kontakte mit
Präsident beiden aber diese Kontakte
müssen sehr gründlich vorbereitet werden
und wir müssen wissen worauf das
Ergebnis hinauslaufen soll
ich kann nicht sagen ob wir auf dem
richtigen Weg sind oder nicht wir werden
es wissen sobald die amerikanische
Antwort vorliegt
also sie wollen im Kontakt bleiben aber
eben zwei sehr unterschiedliche
narrative also lavrov sagte auch noch
man verstehe die ganze Hysterie
eigentlich nicht mit den Soldaten an der
Grenze zu Ukraine wie soll man da auf
einen gemeinsamen Nenner kommen hat sich
da heute irgendwas abgezeichnet an
Kompromiss Dialogbereitschaft
das ist in der Tat die große Frage weil
da zwei narrative gegeneinander stehen
russland hat ja auch zugegeben dass man
Soldaten an der ukrainischen Grenze
versammelt hat und es sollen nach
Informationen von westlichen
Geheimdiensten eben über 100.000 sein
warum ein Land über 100.000 Soldaten an
der Grenze eines Nachbarlandes
versammelt teilweise auch sehr schweres
Gerät dorthin bringt das ist eben die
große Frage auf die ist keine Antwort
gibt es muss eine Drohgebärde sein es
muss auch die Möglichkeit da sein dass
man eben die Ukraine angreift zumal es
ja bereits einen Präzedenzfall gibt 2014
als die Russland die Krim
völkerrechtswidrig für sich eingenommen
hat insofern die Gefahr ist durchaus
real das wird ja auch immer wieder von
allen westlichen Diplomaten und
Politikern betont auf diese Gefahr muss
man eingehen
und ja das ist natürlich dann die große
Frage wenn Russland diese Gefahr negiert
und sagt die bestehe gar nicht
gleichzeitig aber solche Schritte
unternehmen und Soldaten der versammelt
wie passt das zusammen dafür gibt es
bisher meines Erachtens keine plausible
Erklärung kommen wir zu Anthony blinken
und dem amerikanischen narrativ also
blinken und lavrov die haben auf
getrennten Pressekonferenzen heute
besprochen auch sehr interessant und
blinken hat dann noch mal ganz klar
betont dass die USA die Souveränität der
Ukraine unterstützen und diese
Destabilisierung soll erst genannt des
Landes nicht dulden da hören wir auch
noch mal kurz in seinen Statement rein
die Gespräche mit Außenminister lavrov
heute waren offen ich habe die Position
der USA und der EU vorgetragen wir
stehen fest an der Seite der Ukraine
unterstützen ihre Souveränität und ihre
territoriale Integrität wir sind uns
klar sollten russische Kräfte in
irgendeiner Weise die ukrainische Grenze
überschreiten ist dies eine Invasion
darauf werden die USA und ihre Partner
schnell und umfassend und gemeinsam
reagieren
wir erwarten dass wir mit Russland
unsere Bedenken und Ideen etwas
ausführlicher in der nächsten Woche
schriftlich austauschen danach werden
weitere Gespräche folgen wir sind uns
auch einig das weitere diplomatische
Gespräche der bevorzugte Weg sind aber
es ist an Russland zu entscheiden
welchen Weg wir einschlagen
das war jetzt also ja nur der Auftakt
für eben diese gemeinsamen Gespräche was
ist deine Einschätzung Florian was
glaubst du wie weit wird der Westen
vielleicht auch Russland Entgegenkommen
weil da wurden ja schon auch klare
Forderungen benannt
naja erstmal Entgegenkommen davon ist
jetzt die nicht die Rede es geht darum
abzustrecken man will abschrecken damit
Russland eben nicht einen solchen
Schritt eingreift man muss bei dieser
Pressekonferenz von blinken auch auf die
Zwischentöne hören wir haben es gerade
in dem Ausschnitt gehört er sagte selbst
ein Eingreifen ein kleines Eingreifen
jeder ist jeder soldatische Invasion
sozusagen sei eine Invasion und das
greift noch mal auf die Verwirrung der
letzten Tage die blinken Chef nämlich
US-Präsident Joe Biden gestiftet hat der
hatte ja offenbar eher vielleicht
zufällig oder verräterischer Weise
differenziert zwischen einem kleinen
Eingriff einem kleinen Einmarsch und
einem größeren Einmarsch das war eine
diplomatische Verwirrung die dann
erstmal wieder sozusagen einkassiert
werden musste auch das versucht Anthony
blinken mit solchen Aussagen dass er
sagt jeder Eingriff jeder Einmarsch eine
Soldaten ist ein Einmarsch auf den wir
reagieren werden wir der Westen und
insofern es geht hier tatsächlich noch
darum Russland abzuhalten von einem
solchen Schritt mit Drohungen und dann
ist die spannende Frage in einem zweiten
Schritt welche Drohungen kann am besten
wirklich aussprechen und da stellen wir
fest in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
dass es da noch erhebliche Fragezeichen
gibt welche Sanktionen der Westen
wirklich aussprechen kann und wird wir
hören in den letzten beiden Tagen dass
nichts wirklich vom Tisch genommen wird
auch etwa die sogenannte Atomwaffe wie
es immer heißt nämlich der
auslandsausschluss Russlands aus dem
Zahlungssystem Swift das also russische
Banken vom Zahlungsverkehr abgeschnitten
werden sollen das sei weiterhin auf dem
Tisch betonen uns gegenüber Diplomaten
in den Hintergrundgesprächen aber es
gibt eben noch keine keine öffentliche
Kommunikation darüber welche Sanktionen
man dann ergreifen wird in einem solchen
Fall und das ist dann die große Frage
wie einig ist sich der Westen dann wie
groß wie entschieden wird der Westen
werden die Alliierten gemeinsam
reagieren wenn es zu einer Invasion
Russlands in die Ukraine kommen sollte
wir haben es am Anfang auch schon gehört
von dir und auch von naproff also
Russland wartet da jetzt auch erstmal
auf ein Papier was von der
amerikanischen Seite verfasst werden
soll mit Ideen mit aber auch natürlich
den Problemen die genannt werden das hat
zumindest blinken gesagt also er will
die Probleme auch reinschreiben lavroff
hofft auf Ideen Lösungen dort zu hören
wie lange könnte das jetzt dauern bis es
da weitergeht bis es da also wirklich in
eine nächste Runde geht
das wird schon noch ein paar Tage dauern
die Antwort der Amerikaner auf diese
russischen Forderung ist für die nächste
Woche angekündigt
sicherlich werden die Amerikaner sich
vorher auch nochmal intensiv mit den
Europäern besprechen die nächste
Gelegenheit dazu ist am Montag da
treffen sich die EU-Außenministerin und
Außenminister in Brüssel und offenbar
soll auch der US-Außenminister dazu
geschaltet werden dann wird man
gemeinsam diese Antwort formulieren und
sie abschicken und dann wird sicherlich
Russland noch ein paar Tage Zeit
benötigen oder auch einfordern um diese
Antwort zu prüfen aber es könnte dann ja
möglicherweise schon Ende nächster Woche
ein nächstes Treffen geben das aber ist
alles noch im Rahmen der Spekulation
auch bei der Frage wie Russland eben auf
diese Antwort der Amerikaner und des
Westens reagieren wird
danke für diese Einschätzung Florian
Neuhann nach Genf
und jetzt sprechen wir die ganze Zeit
über die Ukraine und den Konflikt aber
jetzt haben wir vor allem die
Möglichkeit eine Stimme aus der Ukraine
zu hören unsere Reporterin meine
Kollegin Anna Feist ist nämlich in Kiew
in der Ukraine wie ist die Stimmung in
der Ukraine gibt es da tatsächlich Sorge
Angst dass da also Soldaten jetzt
einmarschieren könnten wie fühlt sich
das für die Menschen an
ihr Herr Präsident selenski hat zur Ruhe
aufgerufen er sagte das Risiko eines
Angriffs ist nicht gestiegen es ist der
Rummel der angestiegen ist und er bat
die Bevölkerung abzusehen von
Hamsterkäufen und keine größeren
Bargeldsummen abzuheben hier in Kiew ist
schon so eine latente Kriegsangst da das
sieht man daran dass ich in den
vergangenen Wochen viele Menschen den
Reservisten angeschlossen haben und sich
zu Reservisten ausbilden lassen und um
im Zweifel einsatzbereit zu sein
wenn man allerdings sich näher Richtung
Grenze bewegt soll es so sein dass die
Kriegsangst nachlässt weil die Leute
eben oder die Menschen dort gewohnt sind
in kriegsähnlichen Zuständen zu leben
und genau das ist so ein bisschen das
Bild was wir hier gespiegelt bekommen
haben
russische Außenminister labroff hatte
heute auch noch mal immer wieder gesagt
sie hätten ja gar nicht vor ein zu
marschieren also so sagt Russland
gleichzeitig fühlt sich das wie das
beschrieben hast für manche natürlich
bedrohlich an es gab aber auch Meldungen
darüber dass es auch teilweise jetzt
Bedrohungssituation im Land gab was
weißt du darüber
es gibt gezielte die
sterilisierungskampagnen vor wenigen
Tagen gab es einen großen Cyberangriff
der wo vermutet wird das Russland
dahinter steckt und dann gibt es seit
Januar gab es über 200 Drohungen
öffentliche Institutionen Schulen
Supermärkte
anzugreifen mit Terroranschlägen und
erst heute am Vormittag standen tausende
Schüler hier in Kiew auf der Straße und
mussten evakuiert werden weil es am
Vormittag eine Meldung gab an die
Behörden das wohl alle Kia Verschulen
mit Sprengsätzen übersät worden sind
diese Meldungen haben sich in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder als
Fehlmeldungen als Falschmeldungen
rausgestellt wo es einfach darum geht
Unsicherheit zu stiften die ukrainischen
Behörden haben versucht nachzuverfolgen
woher diese Meldungen kommen das sind
meistens E-Mails gewesen und sind da
eben haben die zurückzuverfolgt und sie
haben hingeführt zu Separatisten
Gebieten und zu Belarus ob das
tatsächlich so ist und so stimmt kann
ich an dieser Stelle nicht
nachvollziehen und nicht nachprüfen aber
da geht es wie gesagt um
Destabilisierung und um Unsicherheit und
Ängste schüren danke für diese Einblicke
in die Ukraine danke Anna falls
und jetzt gibt es diesen Konflikt also
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine nicht
erst seit gestern den gibt es schon sehr
sehr lange und um den zu verstehen ist
es vielleicht auch mal ganz gut sich
eine Chronologie anzuschauen einen
Zeitstrahl und den haben wir für euch
vorbereitet ein Bericht von Thomas
Gonsior
Anfang 2014 seit Wochen gibt es Proteste
auf dem Maidan in Kiew gegen die
Abwendung der Ukraine vom Westen
zuvor hatte Präsident Januar kowitsch
ein Assoziierungsabkommen mit der EU auf
Eis gelegt und sich stattdessen Russland
zugewandt dann der 20 februar 2014
Sicherheitskräfte eröffnen auf dem
main-darm das Feuer mehr als 100 pro
europäische Regierungsgegner sterben
Janukowitsch flieht aus Kiew das
Parlament enthebt Ihnen das Amtes
kündigt neue Präsidentschaftswahlen an
kurz danach Russland startet an der
ukrainischen Grenze eine Militärübung
mit 150.000 Soldaten pro russische
Milizen besetzen das Parlament auf der
Halbinsel Krim
bewaffnete Soldaten ohne
Hoheitsabzeichen übernehmen die
Kontrolle über cremeflughäfen auf der
Halbinsel landen nach ukrainischen
Angaben 2000 russische Soldaten
Moskau nimmt die Krim offiziell in die
Russische Föderation auf Folge EU und
USA verhängen Sanktionen gegen Russland
in der Ostukraine besetzen pro russische
Separatisten Verwaltungsgebäude sie
rufen sogenannte unabhängige
Volksrepubliken aus Start eines
bewaffneten Konflikts mit bis heute mehr
als 13.000 Toten
der pro-europäische petroporoschenko
gewinnt die ukrainische
Präsidentschaftswahl er unterzeichnet
das auf Eis gelegte
Assoziierungsabkommen mit der EU die
Folge Russland droht mit ernsten
Konsequenzen
Minsk Friedensverhandlungen der Westen
und Russland nehmen teil eine Waffenruhe
wird beschlossen eingehalten wird sie
nicht
an der Krim rammt Russlands Küstenwache
ein ukrainisches Marineschiff beschießt
weitere es ist die erste offen
militärische Konfrontation zwischen der
Ukraine und Russland
Russland zieht an der Grenze zur Ukraine
Truppen und zehntausende Soldaten
zusammen und zieht sie nach Protesten
des Westens und Kiews wieder ab
Dezember russlands Präsident Putin
fordert schriftliche Zusagen der Westen
soll auf eine nato-ost-erweiterung
verzichten ebenso auf
us-militärstützpunkte in der ehemals
sowjetischen einflussfähre US-Präsident
beiden droht Putin greife Russland die
Ukraine an gebe es Wirtschaftssanktionen
Putin verlangt die Ukraine dürfe kein
NATO-Mitglied werden
Januar zahlreiche diplomatische
Bemühungen bleiben ohne greifbare
Ergebnisse
Moskau macht weiter mobil hat mehr als
100.000 Soldaten an der ukrainischen
Grenze sagen die USA und werfen Moskau
vor einen Vorwand für einen Einmarsch
vorzubereiten Russland dementiert
da war viel drin und wir haben viele
Fragen ich habe sie auch gesehen im
Stream von euch die können wir jetzt
alle Stellen an den ehemaligen
Nato-General Egon Rams schönen guten
Abend Herr Rams
schönen guten Abend lassen sie uns
vielleicht am Anfang direkt mal über
diese russische Strategie sprechen
100.000 Soldaten sollen es sein die da
also an der Grenze zur Ukraine stehen
auch wenn immer betont wird man hätte
nicht vor mit denen einzumarschieren das
war ja alles nur eine Übung sie sollen
an mehreren Teilen entlang der Grenze
stehen was genau ist da los wie ist das
einzuordnen
also die Soldaten die sich jetzt in der
Nähe der Ukraine befinden sei es im
Osten sei es aber auch im Norden der
Ukraine sind keine organischen
Truppenteile die normalerweise in diesem
Bereich des Militärbezirk West von
Russland stationiert sind sondern es
handelt sich um ein amigur aus dem aus
der Oblast Novosibirsk und ein weiteres
amicor aus dem Nordkaukasus die
tropendiens in den letzten Tagen auch in
Belarus oder nach Belarus Süd in den
Süden verlegt worden sind kann ich im
Augenblick noch nicht lokalisieren aber
insgesamt recht das alles dazu bei dass
die tropenstärke im militärbezeug West
der an die Ukraine angrenzt von Seiten
der Russen deutlich erhöht worden ist
dazu gehören auch kleinere Verbände wie
beispielsweise zwei zusätzliche
bannionen die auf die Krim verlegt
worden sind das alles wenn man nach dem
Sinn fragt muss man sich schon Gedanken
darüber machen warum man das verfolgt
und warum auf diese Art und Weise
Einfluss möglicherweise auf die Ukraine
auch nicht möglicherweise durch
militärischen Angriff aber Einfluss
genommen werden soll
wie sieht es denn aus auf der
ukrainischen Seite also da es heißt ja
auch immer wieder beide Länder werfen
sich vor sich nicht in das
minsker-abkommen nicht an den
Friedensplan zu halten wie sieht's aus
auf der anderen Seite in der Ukraine
die Ukraine verfügt über ihre regulären
Streitkräfte das sind etwa 200.000
Soldaten sie verfügt über einen relativ
großen Anteil an Reservisten die ich
etwa auf 100.000 Schätze und zur
verfügte die Nationalgarde mit 80.000
aber das sind alles legitime Truppen die
in normal in der Ukraine stationiert
sind von denen auch einige oder eine
ganze Reihe eingesetzt ist in den
ablasten suchanskondon jetzt um auf
diese Art und Weise die Separatisten in
Schach zu halten die Aussage dass man
sich nicht an die Minsker Abkommen hält
ist richtig aber sie gilt und
verstärkter Maße für die Separatisten
und die OSZE die ja über die münzke
Abkommen eigentlich als Beobachter
eingesetzt worden sind sind bisher über
die Grenze Richtung Russland um dort zu
inspizieren nicht zugelassen worden von
daher man kann sich da fragen wer denn
möglicherweise bestehende Verträge oder
geschlossene Verträge nicht einhält
wir haben die erste Frage dazu auch aus
dem Stream von nicojo bei Youtube er
oder sie fragt welche Zugeständnisse
will denn die NATO USA an Russland
machen die NATO nicht vor der Haustür
haben zu wollen kann man aus russischer
Sicht ja teilweise verstehen schreibt er
oder sie
verstehen kann man vieles aber wir
müssen zurück gucken auf das Jahr 1990
mit der Karte von Paris Russland der ich
sag mal neuen Ordnung nach dem
Zusammenbruch des warschauerpaktes
zugestimmt hat das heißt das war damals
sogar noch die Sowjetunion und was
gucken auf die Grundlagen der NATO
Russland Grundlagen des
grundlagenvertrages auch hier ist über
eine mögliche Erweiterung gesprochen
worden das ist sogar davon gesprochen
worden in dieser Grundakte das
vorübergehend allerdings keine
substantiellen Truppenteile in diesen
Länder stationiert werden können das
heißt das ist Russland bekannt und dass
man jetzt dagegen angeht ist eine Sache
die sich über die letzten Jahre so
entwickelt hat und man gewinnt den
Eindruck dass offensichtlich die
Interpretation sowohl der
Waffenstillstandsabkommen von Minsk als
auch der grundlagenverträge der OSZE bis
zurück zum ksze-vertrag und die Karte
von Paris offensichtlich unterschiedlich
interpretiert werden
ich habe heute gesehen es gibt einen
Tweet von der russischen Botschaft in
Großbritannien da Schlüssel die im
Prinzip auf dass Russland ja immer
beschuldigt also verschiedenster Dinge
beschuldigt wird dazu zählt dass sie
ihre Truppen im eigenen Land hin und her
bewegen und kritisieren damit auch dass
nicht sich von Westseite daran gehalten
wird dass Russland ja immer wieder
fordert eine Null NATO-Truppen Regel
quasi in Osteuropa würden Sie sagen man
ist vielleicht aber auch zu wenig auf
Russland bislang bislang zugegangen oder
wie würden sie das einschätzen
also es gibt dann interessantes Signal
bereits aus dem Jahre 2001 damals hat
Putin im Deutschen Bundestag seine
berühmte Rede gehalten die von den
Medien und allen Parteien entsprechend
positiv begrüßt worden ist aber in
dieser Rede gibt es auch eine Passage wo
Putin gesagt hat andere Fällen
Entscheidungen und bereiten
Entscheidungen vor und verlangen dann
von Russland obwohl Russland an der
Entscheidungsvorbereitung nicht
beteiligt war das Russland diese
Entscheidung mit vollzieht das war
sicherlich damals ein Hinweis den er
gegeben hat und der sich in Teilen auch
in den letzten Jahren ich sage das mal
so in dieser Form weiter fortgesetzt hat
das Entscheidung getroffen worden sind
und Russland praktisch bei diesen
Entscheidungen dann auch nur Zuschauer
war aber ich möchte auf einen Punkt in
aller Deutlichkeit Hinweisen wir reden
bei der Ukraine wir reden bei den
baltischen Staaten bei Polen Bulgarien
Rumänien
sogar bei Schweden und Finnland von
souveränen Staaten die selber darüber
entscheiden welchem Sicherheitssystem
sie beitreten oder durch welches System
sie sich entsprechend schützen lassen
und da hat Russland keine
Einflussmöglichkeiten wenn wir
Völkerrecht zugrunde liegen und das
scheint offensichtlich Putin auch mit
seinem Forderungskatalog aus dem aus dem
Dezember vergessen zu haben denn dieser
Forderungskatalog ist ja im Prinzip wenn
Sie so wollen die Auflistung einer Reihe
von Forderungen für die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands
in dem aber auf die internationalen
Regeln auf die internationalen Verträge
keine Rücksicht genommen wird
ich lese bei uns im Stream deswegen muss
ich sie auch danach fragen schon auch
ein bisschen sorgenvolle stimmen also
zum Beispiel laura-marie fragt sich bei
Youtube ob sie als Normalsterblicher
Mensch in Deutschland nun Angst vor
einem Dritten Weltkrieg haben muss
also ich halte Präsident Putin und ich
halte auch Russland insgesamt immer noch
für so vernünftig dass ein solcher Krieg
nicht vom Zaun gebrochen wird und ich
möchte in dem Zusammenhang auch mal
deutlich betonen dass die NATO die ja
1949 gegründet worden ist und bis heute
und das sind jetzt mehr als 70 Jahre nie
einen Krieg angefangen hat nie einen
Angriff gemacht hat oder dergleichen
Dinge mehr das ist erstmal eine ganz
einfache Feststellung wenn wir diese
Bilanz auf Russland drauflegen sieht das
Stichwort Krim Stichwort Moldawien
Stichwort andere Länder wie
beispielsweise Georgien etwas anders aus
so von daher wenn man über diese
Situation sprechen will dann muss man a
feststellen die NATO ist ein
Verteidigungsbündnis und hat sich an
diese Regel bisher immer gehalten das
ist der eine Teil dabei und Russland
muss vielleicht auch mal über seine
eigene Position nachdenken und das ist
das was ich mir erhoffe aus den
Gesprächen die jetzt aufgenommen worden
sind möglicherweise auch den
schriftlichen Antworten der Amerikaner
dass hier einiges klargestellt wird und
man tatsächlich dann zu substanziellen
Gesprächen kommt bei denen man nicht so
wie heute möglicherweise aneinander
vorbei redet
noch vielleicht im aber noch mal eine
Frage aus dieser sorgenvollen Ecke auch
noch mal aufzugreifen also Alvin Hansa
liegt bei youtube hat sich beide
Statements angeschaut von amerikanischer
und russischer Seite und stellt sich nun
die Frage was tut die NATO oder was
würde die NATO EU tun sollte Russland
einmarschieren
bisher hat man sich von amerikanischer
Seite aber auch in den Aussagen der EU
und der NATO darauf beschränkt dass man
mit entsprechenden Sanktionen
überwiegend im wirtschaftlichen Bereich
gedroht hat und auch Deutschland die
Außenministerin und der Kanzler haben
gesagt dass alle Optionen auf dem Tisch
liegen und das in dem Falle wenn sowas
passieren wollte dann die entsprechenden
Optionen gezogen werden ich sehe das
zurzeit nicht so dass nato-eu oder
Amerikaner militärisch in der Ukraine
Eingreifen werden aber sie werden
Ukraine und ukrainische Streitkräfte
sicherlich weiterhin mit
Waffenlieferungen und dergleichen
unterstützen wobei Deutschland ja
Waffenlieferung für sich ausgeschlossen
hat
da hätte ich sie jetzt auch noch mal
drauf angesprochen genau in Deutschland
hat das ausgeschlossen wie sollte
Deutschland jetzt aber grundsätzlich
reagieren wenn das jetzt nicht teil von
einer Reaktion ist
also wir haben ja oft über das Thema
nordstream gesprochen und in den Medien
ist doch viel darüber berichtet worden
in den letzten Wochen
ich glaube dass wenn tatsächlich ein
militärischer Angriff über die Grenze
der Ukraine erfolgt
wir Nord Stream tatsächlich zur
Disposition stellen müssen wobei man
sich heute schon die Frage stellen muss
ob diese Abhängigkeit von Russland über
die Energieversorgung über Nord Stream 1
und Nord Stream 2 und wir beziehen ja
auch noch Erdöl aus Russland dass das
eine Situation ist wo ich sage es ist
auch nicht günstig wenn man von einem
anderen Land in diesem Umfang mit
Energielieferungen oder von
Energielieferung abhängig ist das ist
sicherlich auch ein Kriterium dabei aber
das ist sicherlich ein Thema welches
auch Russland ganz empfindlich treffen
würde allerdings wären auch Teile der
deutschen Industrie deutsche Firmen die
Geld dafür zur Verfügung gestellt haben
damit möglicherweise betroffen
dazu passt die Frage von Nicola bei
Youtube die sich fragt wie kann der
politische Westen glaubwürdig die
Ukraine beschützen wenn schon offen
kommuniziert wurde dass die Ukraine
keinen militärischen Schutz erhalten
wird
also durch Unterstützung auf alle Arten
und Weisen wie es seit 2014 erfolgt also
wenn Sie die ukrainische Streitkräfte im
Zustand 2014 nehmen und sie mit den
ukrainischen Streitkräften heute 2022
vergleichen dann sind diese Streitkräfte
deutlich besser ausgerüstet wird
deutlich besser ausgebildet und die
ukrainischen Soldaten das ukrainische
Volk hat offensichtlich auch ein
entsprechenden verteidigungswillen
entwickelt zumindest mit der Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung wird dieses so gesehen
und von der ukanischen Bevölkerung auch
so entsprechend unterstützt das heißt
die Situation ist eine andere geworden
aber es geht nicht nur das ist auch ein
wichtiger Punkt glaube ich um das was
dann möglicherweise mit dem
Überschreiten von militärischen Stiefeln
der Grenze bedeutet sondern es geht vor
allen Dingen auch um Dinge wie
beispielsweise Cyberkrieg oder hybrider
Krieg also sprich Einflussnahmen auf
ukrainische Firmen durch Cyberangriffe
Einflussnahme auf die Ukraine durch ein
droht ihr und dergleichen Dinge mehr
auch dieses sind Dinge die müssen
schlicht und einfach aufhören denn die
Ukraine als Ganzes das heißt das
schließt auch du kannst gondon jetzt
obwohl die ihre Unabhängigkeit erklärt
haben oder autonome Republiken erklärt
haben sind damit einzuschließen auf der
Karte von Paris auf dieser Basis und auf
den Ball auf der Basis internationaler
Verträge hat die Ukraine ein Recht in
ihren damals bestehenden Grenzen als
freies Land weiter zu agieren und sich
frei zu entscheiden für welche Zuordnung
Westen Osten oder neutral sich dann
selber entscheiden ich möchte dazu noch
einen Satz hinzufügen diese Forderungen
die Putin aufgestellt hat vor
Weihnachten vorgelegt hat können Sie ja
auch übertragen auf Schweden und
Finnland das heißt wenn Schweden und
Finnland sich entscheiden würden der
NATO beizutreten würde Putin in gleicher
Art und Weise agieren oder handeln und
das ist einfach nicht hinnehmbar
gehen wir noch mal ganz kurz an die
Grenze jetzt hat die Grenze von Kinder
gehen noch mal ganz kurz zurück an das
Thema mit der Grenze das wollte ich
sagen ich habe dazu nämlich auch noch
Fragen im Stream gesehen also stand
jetzt soll es so sein dass da bis zu
100.000 Soldaten eben von russischer
Seite an der Grenze zur Ukraine stehen
gleichzeitig hat der Außenminister
lavroff heute immer wieder gesagt na ja
sie hätten ja gar nicht vor ein zu
marschieren aber wieso ist Russland dann
in dieser Truppenstärke wenn dem dann so
ist dort aktuell vertreten wie lesen Sie
das
also ich sehe das so ich sehe das so
dass ich sage damit wenn politische
Ziele verfolgt und ein Teil der
politischen Ziele hat der Präsident
Putin ja auch erreicht durch diesen
Aufmarsch und diese Übungen und den
verbleibt dieser Truppenteile in den
Übungsräumen hat er erreicht dass er
Gespräche selber mit Joe Biden geführt
hat dass diese Verhandlungen aufgenommen
werden die Gespräche zwischen Anthony
blinken und Außenminister lavrov
stattfinden und dergleichen mehr das
heißt russland hat sich damit aus einer
ich nenne das mal einer gewissen
Isolation herausgelöst und eines der
Ziele von Präsident Putin wird sein in
der Weltpolitik mit Russland eine
entsprechende Rolle zu spielen und ein
weiteres Ziel ist dass er sich einen ein
Cordon Sanitär aufbauen will der
Russland herumgezogen wird wo er keine
NATO Truppenteile mehr sehen möchte und
dergleichen mehr und der hat ja auch die
Forderung gestellt sogar heute noch
durch lavrov das beispielsweise aus
Bulgarien Rumänien nato-truppenteile
abgezogen werden soll und das ist
einfach eine Forderung die ist nicht
rechtfertigen denn Bulgarien Rumänien
haben sich entschieden
NATO-Mitglieder zu werden sind
NATO-Mitglieder geworden und aus dem
Grunde dürfen sich NATO-Truppen dort
auch aufhalten nicht wiederhole meinen
Satz den ich gerade schon gesagt habe
die Naht war bisher in ihrer Geschichte
seit 1949 noch kein Land angegriffen
dazu passt trotzdem noch eine Frage aus
dem Stream sie kommen also immer wieder
diese Fragen deswegen will ich sie gerne
stellen und kurz auch noch der Hinweis
die Bilder die wir gerade in dem
Gespräch noch mit ihnen gesehen haben
die sollen nämlich also die russischen
Soldaten an der Grenze zu Ukraine zeigen
meine Frage an Sie jetzt aber nehme ich
aus dem Stream von Sven Meißner bei
Facebook möchte er wissen warum steht
die NATO seit einem Jahr an der
russischen Grenze warum wurde im letzten
Jahr so viel Kriegsmaterial da
hochgeschickt wenn die NATO nicht vor
hat anzugreifen wie sie auch gesagt
haben
jetzt muss ich eine Gegenfrage stellen
wohin es Kriegsmaterial gestrickt worden
in die Ukraine ja das hat Herr Meissner
nicht weiter ausgeführte du hast noch
kurz Zeit wenn Meißner das noch zu
präzisieren aber kommen wir zur ersten
Frage also warum
NATO-Truppen in der Nähe der russischen
Grenze sind
also NATO-Truppen in der Nähe der
russischen Grenze haben wir außerhalb
der nationalen Streitkräfte
beispielsweise der ballischen Staaten
und der Polen eigentlich nur mit den
sogenannten in harnst forward present
Bataillonen die sich in Estland Lettland
Litauen und und Polen befinden auch hier
hat die NATO als diese Sache entschieden
worden ist der sorgfältig darauf
geachtet dass dadurch bestehende
Verträge beispielsweise die NATO
Russland Grundakte nicht verletzt wird
diese Truppenteile sind dort nicht auf
Dauer stationiert sie rotieren und sie
sind weit unter der Stärke die damals im
Rahmen der NATO Russland Grundakte unter
der unter dem Begriff substanzielle
Kräfte definiert worden sind da hat man
vom Divisionen gesprochen und wir reden
hier über ich sag mal verstärkte
Bataillone von da kann ich die Frage
nicht ganz nachvollziehen dass wir wir
heißt in dem Falle die NATO
Truppenteile in den
NATO-Mitgliedstaaten haben einmal
nationale Trupp aber auch Truppenteile
der NATO zu Übungszwecken und
dergleichen mehr kann durch niemanden
beanstandet und ich niemand verboten
werden
und zum Schluss aber noch die Frage wenn
sie ihn jetzt in die Zukunft schauen und
nächste Woche soll ja wir haben es
angesprochen also eine schriftliche
Antwort der USA erfolgen was glauben Sie
mit all ihrer Erfahrung wie geht es
jetzt weiter
also ich hoffe dass die Amerikaner eine
Antwort geben die ich sag mal zumindest
in Teilen eine Zustimmung der Russen
bekommt und dass dann die Gespräche
zwischen den USA
NATO EU und Russland fortgesetzt werden
denn wenn wir über bestimmte Länder
reden beispielsweise auch über die
Ukraine reden dann sollten wir nicht
über die Ukraine Ukraine reden sondern
auch mit der Ukraine reden das ist mir
ein sehr wichtiger Punkt
zweite Anmerkung dazu wir haben im
ksze-prozess von Helsinki 1975 bis in
die 90er Jahre hinein also über rund 40
Jahre oder rund 30 Jahre Frieden
aufgebaut Vertrauen aufgebaut
vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen
durchgeführt und dazu sollten wir
wiederkommen das bringt mich zu einer
Anmerkung die Truppenbewegungen die
durch die Verlegung aus dem Nordkaukasus
und aus Novosibirsk in den Raum der
Ukraine oder an die Grenze zu Ukraine
erfolgt sind wäre nach dem osze-vertrag
Truppenbewegungen die Moskau hätte
notifizieren müssen und wo man aufgrund
der Stärke auch beobachte hätte zulassen
müssen das ist alles nicht erforcht wir
müssen mal die Frage stellen warum hält
man sich nicht an diese Verträge und
sorgt auf diese Art und Weise dazu das
Misstrauen erst gar nicht entsteht
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung und die
Erklärung an den ehemaligen Nato-General
an Egon Rams vielen Dank
gerne und vielen Dank auch an euch
natürlich wie immer für die Fragen für
die Kommentare und das war es von uns
für diese Woche nächste Woche sind wir
natürlich wieder für Euch da bis dahin
danke und tschüss